the National Security Agency is
investigating a shooting outside its
highly secure headquarters in Maryland
guards stopped an SUV and an entrance to
the campus this morning and shots were
fired sources tell CBS News three people
were injured here one suspect is in
custody Jeff Perez is at the NSA in Fort
Meade Maryland that's northeast of
Washington Jeff good morning good
morning the good news is the situation
appears to be under control there are
police here on the scene
the NSA is to my left we're being told
not to shoot it for security reasons now
here's what happened shortly before the
Sun came up a car slammed into a barrier
at NSA headquarters shots were fired and
you can see that from the windshield of
the vehicle right now and these numbers
are shifting we're being told that three
people were injured they are not gunshot
injuries we're told that they are car
crash injuries but again it is still
early we're also being told if there is
one person that is in custody that is
being questioned and it looks like that
person is cooperating now what this is
we still don't know investigators are
here on the scene and that includes NSA
police that includes the FBI as well so
investigators are still looking into
this it is still early on but obviously
a serious situation at that checkpoint
here at NSA headquarters shots fired
three people injured one person in
custody Nora
all right Jeff thank you so much